in China as in many cultures being tall
has always been prized but as the most
populous country on earth continues to
open its economy to the west Hite has
become not just valued but a
prerequisite for success the combination
of a traditional Chinese ideal of beauty
and the need to interact with taller
Outsiders is leading some to take
measures that many consider very extreme
at four feet eight inches tall Sudan is
one of millions of people in China who
feel they've been punished for being too
short I've thought about this problem
ever since I can understand I want to be
taller but to realize his dreams he must
embark on a grueling and per minute
shopping procedure so taboo he won't
show his face on television dr. Rubin
Yuda has seen this before he specializes
in an operation that most people would
find unthinkable he stretches legs it's
at Rast extent but at the number-8
people's hospital hundreds of patients
have gladly yet secretly gone under the
knife the procedure is expensive painful
and can take a year of recovery while
bone stretching is performed elsewhere
in the world it has taken hold here in
China in a nation of a billion people
competing for jobs and for each other
height has become a critical condition
for success if you lack the proper
tallness you may be denied jobs at banks
government ministries or even College
Admission worse you may be left out of
the dating game anyone who wants to have
their bones stretch will be in for
lengthy trial one that can carry some
serious risks legs can be permanently
weakened or end up uneven
to avoid excessive risk Fudan is given a
local anesthetic which means he will be
awake for the two hour long procedure
holes are drilled into the bone and a
system of braces is screwed in place
they may look medieval but they are the
key to stabilizing the leg once the bone
has been cut the shin bone is severed at
the end where it can regenerate itself
but it must be cut precisely too much
and there could be permanent damage to
the marrow in dr. Rulon's procedure
nothing is placed in the leg to make it
longer instead the bone will grow into
the gap harnessing the body's own
healing power though the operation is
over it's far too soon to know how much
boudin will grow nothing is more
gratifying for patients and doctors than
the day the braces come off for Wang Lee
after a process that has taken one long
year that day has finally come this time
it's the operation in Reverse first the
struts are removed then the screws are
painfully taken out from the bone now
the patient can walk away by herself now
I feel more natural more normal and I
feel much happier
a year and four inches later miss Wong
is ready to rejoin society taller and
more confident it's something Fudan has
to look forward to a long way from now